i started writing code when i was 10
years old um it wasn't something in
school something was just pure curiosity
i had it fast forward um
i got to the eight one unit in the in
the intelligence forces here in israel
um spent five years graduated as captain
and then when they left the army
it was pretty clear to me that
i am going to open my own company
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
all right welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today i'm with lyran
hassan the co-founder and ceo of aporia
a full-stack machine learning
observability platform used by fortune
500 companies and data science teams
across the world to ensure responsible
ai
prior to founding aporia leron was an ml
architect at microsoft acquired adelum
and later on an investor at vertex
ventures
niran created aporia after seeing
firsthand the effects of ai without
guardrails certainly a crazy world we
live in and i'm really excited for this
conversation with lyran
[Music]
i get to ask you my favorite question
which is why do you do what you do
why do you wake up every day
running this crazy startup looking at
machine learning observability and data
science in general uh what what is sort
of your north star and why do you have
the coolest job in the world so i'd love
to hear more about you
oh well
uh yeah i have a lot to say about that
so
there are a few questions what you ask
like why am i running a company from the
very beginning then why specifically
machine learning and effort what
specifically observability for animation
like so this is kind of
the way it's here
so first where do i
why did i start my own company in
general
well i started writing code when i was
10 years old
it wasn't something in school something
was just pure curiosity i had a good
friend of mine who was able to build a
website gave me a call
really read to me at 200 characters
address website address i remember
typing it in my computer and then i saw
his website and for me it was like
mind-blowing the fact that he built
something on his computer
and i can open it and access it from my
computer it was crazy
um so it got me super curious about how
do you create this thing
and then i started really creating uh
websites so learning um html and then
asp and then other languages some of
them are not in existence or it not
being used today anymore
but really
what got me engaged so so much as a kid
um was about
having some things in idea in your mind
and then really designing it back in the
day i was using photoshop for depth and
then really actually taking this graphic
implementing writing developing it and
make it real so people can actually use
them
um
there were a couple of projects today
that was a lot about creation it was
amazing uh from my experience
so
fast forward um
i got to the eight one unit in the in
the intelligence forces here in israel
um spent five years graduated as captain
and then when they left the army
it was pretty clear to me that
i am going to open my own company
i really like creating
in general but more specifically i like
creating products you know like creating
teams um up until this date i'm still in
touch with
like one of my best some of my best
friends
where
my my subordinates from the army
wow
so it was all about that and it was
really every decision i made in my
career was about
what's going to provide me with
more skills more experience that will
make me a better ceo a better founder
one day when i will open my own company
was it a trivial um
a trivial progression for you from from
researcher engineer very detail-oriented
very execution-based to now more of a
leadership style that now you're you
know you're being measured not by your
own work but by the work of your
subordinates or team members in the
army's perspective or now you know by
the company that you're running i guess
you don't get to write much code in you
know in the day-to-day
yeah although last week um i was able to
help in some engineering issues that we
faced so
oh but yeah i'm generally i'm not
writing code today
um was it natural it's a good question i
feel like
you know it's really about how you feel
new you are as a personality um in my
last role in the army
um that was kind of the things i was
doing so i was managing a team of people
but i was writing code i was managing
the people we had a project that
included thousands of people that are
really i was really leading the
direction of this project
um
i wouldn't say that they did business
marketing sales back in the day but
then that's exactly what i looked for in
my next positions right so when i joined
andalon as one of the first two plays
i was really curious to find a place
where i'll get the first
the this sit in the front row
to see how a startup is being built
but also on the business line um and i'm
like super thankful for adolescent
founders who gave me the opportunity
to go travel to the us meet with our
prospects
uh you know it's not so obvious to take
a software engineer
and put him against like in the room
with fortune 500 company and let him
lead the technical discussion
um so right this is an amazing
opportunity that i have
and really i think in adulthood i got
exposed
to how sales is done how marketing is
done before at all like for me marketing
and sales consider as the same thing
um
so i think adolin was amazing school for
me to learn all these things
and then moving on to vertex ventures
more being on faster side allowed me to
gain some more insight about why some
companies are most successful while
others are less um how should i evaluate
different market opportunities as well
as when building a company how should
you you know
choose your board members if you have
this luxury um and stuff like that so
right i did board with i wasn't born
with you know all this knowledge but
it's something i accumulated over time
and i'm still learning i think the most
important thing in the startup is really
to learn every day
so it sounds like through a variety of
experiences you you got to to to really
do a deep dive into these different
aspects which now you're you obviously
have to consolidate yourself as a leader
and then transitioning more too to the
machine learning aspect and sort of the
domain that you've chosen to run a
company you know you're you're at a
position
after being a principal investor at
vertex which is a phenomenal phenomenal
fund um and you you now say okay what do
i want to do what is sort of the thing
that i want to work on for the next 10
years that will be the most meaningful
and fulfilling for me and my team how do
you converge on on your world why is
machine learning observability
and the problems that you're solving why
are they so fascinating for you
right so
it wasn't the first
option or the first time i was you know
introduced with the idea of starting a
company in a specific field but i
actually waited from the moment i left
the army till i started up for you for
five years for the right moment and the
right opportunity so what what was in
there um and i'd say there were two main
things
so
the first thing for me it was
really about the opportunity to do
something impactful
right and when you think about ai
um
you really see ai taking over
um and ai becoming as large as software
and maybe the future is going to be even
larger than software
um and it's really getting into every
vertical whether it's healthcare
financials
autonomous cars it's really everywhere
in every vertical
now
when you think about the impact
of all these models there of
this technology it really allows us as
society to do things that were
considered as if possible or very very
costly before right
now if you think about it um very
similarly to software ai
will say like it's the unfortunate
reality that we're living in and
therefore every place that will in every
organization that will adopt he's
adopting and will atop the ai
they will have to have
something to monitor their machine
learning models
and really
having an observability solution is no
less than enabler for this
technology
so this is the first reason and then the
second one
is about the market opportunity here
right
so
i was i was waiting for five views i
really wanted to build
a large company um not talking about
valuation by the way not talking about
either revenues or how many employees
but rather
having a company building a company
where
we build a product that our customers
our users really enjoyed using it really
driving and deriving value from this
product
when the question of for you all comes
to place it's not a question it's pretty
clear
so this was uh one thing about it and
the second is to build a place where
people are coming and starting the work
day with a clear understanding of why
they're doing what they're doing what's
the impact of what they're doing so
clarify for me a little bit about this
the notion of deriving value from the
product because you know on one hand
you're saying this is not you know when
you sing big company we're not
necessarily talking about valuation or
or or market cap etc but because those
are very quantitative are you talking
about something a little bit more
qualitative which is how much value are
you getting from this how do you as a
ceo sort of
how do you explain now the value that is
being given by aporia or whatever
solution you envision as you as you grow
this company what is this value that is
dramatic for companies
so i think the value is really about you
know
really leveraging ai whether it's
insulin pumps that you want to know
um how to use it and what is the exact
um
the exact ranges in the blood and so on
whether it's autonomous cars which can
save us a lot of times as humanity so
this is the impact really enabling these
things to
be used in real life i think this is the
true impact uh but for that really to
happen
it doesn't it it's not enough to have
you to pay a lot of money for a company
to do that for you but really to use
this solution
so when we look at a company about what
we care about we care about the usage of
our clients with the plot with the
product and one of the things we are
really proud of is to see
our users using the product and not only
they're using it they also
advocate for it and you can see on slack
communities in the envelopes community
indeed communities that people recommend
that you know if you're looking for an
observability solution well you must try
for it they promised he can be up and
running in less than five minutes and it
actually it's actually true so these
kind of things
interesting and so
one thing that we were talking about
here
is the sort of the growth of ai into
every vertical right and the fact that
today machine learning models
you know they're not just for the large
companies that are doing the really
complicated things it's really for every
day
every
probable task that a company may need
they can leverage machine learning in
one way or another so just looking back
to this because i think it's a really
important note
why why is observability important here
i mean you know this is not something
that people talk about often why is this
something that we should that we should
invest in that we should actually care
about is either as a company or somebody
who's using the product of the company
right so let's say what happened if you
wouldn't use if you wouldn't have
observability or monitoring from school
anymore
which basically means that you're led
you're you're creating the model you're
not really looking too much about your
biases your data you're just sort of
letting it run black box and how we say
nebraska
exactly
right so let's say you're very
optimistic and you let them just run
freely i'm an optimist
yep
oh well
so
there are a few examples uh really
unfortunate ones whether it's zillow who
found themselves losing 300 millions of
dollars in revenues um as a result the
very same week their market cap got
sliced in nine billion dollars
um so this is just one simple example
but it's not really only about money um
there were there was an example in where
amazon tries to leverage ai
to prioritize job resume because a lot
of people you know submit their resumes
to to amazon they really just want to
prioritize the more relevant candidates
and while they were actually able
to come up with
very successful models they later on
realize that their models are biased
against women
and this was although they didn't use
gender as an input to their model and
this is really where the challenge lies
right these models are black box it's
not like traditional software
uh so really how do we use this
technology without discriminating
different people with making sure that
everyone has the same equal opportunity
um these days right um how do we make
sure
that ai is being used for good and not
for bad so
it's really about all these questions
why ml observability is so crucial
right so now going going back to sort of
you as the entrepreneur as a ceo and and
a little bit about your take on this and
growing a company what is sort of top of
mind for you as you're navigating
through this you know the awesome
technology the great impact that you're
building
you still
choose to go and fight this every day
into and to create a big company
what what are some things that you're
thinking about what
what what what do you think about before
you go to sleep
oh i'll think about a lot of things
before i go to sleep
um do you want to be more specific
as if as the ceo of a fast-growing
startup that is making a big impact and
your position to hopefully be integrated
into a lot of the work by a lot of
businesses from large to small what are
things that you're that that you're
putting that you're prioritizing as a
ceo as a leader here
sure so
listen we've been able to build an
amazing product but it's not me saying
it's the community saying that
um pretty recently we closed our series
a round and now we're growing very very
rapidly as you mentioned no
it does create some challenges of growth
we have amazing culture here we have the
smartest people here in israel working
on this product
i mean always we are expanding both in
israel and in the us
it raises some new questions right like
how do we keep the culture
as it was before
how do we grow rapidly without breaking
things like it's important to break
things and create them quick but how do
we keep
the things that are important for us the
same way they are or how do we update
them to the new state of the company um
i think this is kind of one of the
things that i'm thinking and
about a lot about
interesting and as you're as you're
obviously having to keep in touch with
the cutting edge of technology and
machine learning
is this a you know a lot of research
that you need to do
how do you balance between your own
offerings versus keeping in touch with
sort of how the long tail of businesses
are leveraging ai today because this is
also changing dramatically year in and
year out we've just seen what's
happening with nlp and and you know the
emergence of nlp now into small
businesses which hasn't really happened
yet but it will obviously emporia is
going to be a a big part of that
yeah absolutely so by the way lpf3 gets
an amazing example right how
in the past you were able to see
democratization of this technology and
when you think about it doing enveloping
traditional software it's much it's it
is much more complex than with tabular
data and that's why you see a lot of
adoption of ml with nlp related use
cases
so as for us
you know and for our product the way we
build our product roadmap
is highly correlated with the market
um
we take a lot of the inputs from our
existing customers as well as we talk
constantly with the market now whether
it's analysts whether it's investors
whether it's potential customers of
course
um really to identify what are the
trends
and what is the best way for them what
are they looking to get from a product
like apporia
and based on that that's how we
prioritize the build up and
in according with that we have also
however an in-house research team which
constantly conducts research for example
in ancient nlp one of the things we are
researching internally is to find better
ways to investigate nlp issues and to
gain insights about how to improve nlp
models
hmm interesting and uh yeah obviously
you know we can all imagine what
happened if a if somebody uses black box
nlp on a
with some bias or in some context that
is not exactly what you intended and
what are the implications of that
as nlp is very human oriented in in the
real world
you know you mentioned that that you're
in all of the the people that you work
with whether it's their intelligence or
their their nature and
if so if you know there's so many
amazing people around the world and i'm
always curious how do you sort of
position emporia as you're as you're
trying to bring them on and and bring
them to your team
what is sort of your persona if you had
to to envision sort of the person the
type of person that you're attracting to
a porya or to your own mission in this
world
what what is this persona what do you
truly care about about the employees
you're asking
yeah who do you want to partner with you
on your journey here
yeah so first i'd say sole players
people who are
really passionate about what they're
doing they care a lot about that
um because really i think there is no
one employee in our company that doesn't
know what we're doing um so this will be
the first thing being the sole player
being part of a family i know there's a
lot of discussion on this company family
or not
um i like i like to call a porya team uh
you know even though we're a couple of
teams um it's still a team it's not a
group of people we're trying to a team
collaborate together
um so it's a lot about the personality
um
winners in their mind like people here
will do everything it takes in order to
win
and you know we'll work the winners
holy days we'll do whatever whatever it
takes in order to win
um
and also people who are very very smart
i usually like to evaluate people on
three different aspects
first would be motivation
then it will be skills and for the
culture of it
so we do look for
you know uh to fill in all these free
chat boxes now when we are evaluating
people to join emporia
and in general when evaluating people i
don't like to call it interviews um i'd
rather believe it more fit and mutual
fit
yeah so
that's kind of the way we also evaluate
these kind of opportunities more whether
it's a mutual fit for us in the
candidate or not
right i mean it sounds like in
especially today rather than maybe even
a few years ago it's much easier to sort
of understand the benchmark of a person
in terms of what they know and what
their current skill sets are which
perhaps was the main
a pro injury process up until a few
years ago but now we have so many ways
of getting these
off the ground that once you actually go
and you start a site a ping pong with
somebody you kind of as you kind of know
that they're you know a right
professional fit now the question is are
you a part of the team and and there you
go comes the winning the winner
mentality the ability to to under to be
truly passionate about what you do and
so on thank you very very much i
appreciate your time i love you know the
problem that you're dealing with i truly
care about
um you know observability and machine
learning and looking a lot as to
fairness and figuring out how the hell
do we make sense of this new world that
we're going into where
everything is going to be driven by
machine learning models and ai models
and
we need a lot of support to be able to
understand what's happening and and when
to pull the brakes and when to push the
gas and it's not trivial so thank you
for your work thank you for your time
and best of luck with aporia thank you
very much michael appreciate your time
thank you
[Music]
you